we now have reason to hope
that by spring community testing and
vaccines will combine
to end this era of restrictions but to
get there
we must first navigate a hard winter
when the
burden on our nhs is heaviest and the
cold weather favors
the virus the data already suggests that
national measures in england have slowed
and in some places reversed the growth
of new cases
and as more data comes in we hope and
expect to see those trends
continue together we have prevented
rnhs from being overwhelmed
but those dangers have not gone away
if we ease off now we risk losing
control of this virus
all over again casting aside our
hard-won gains and forcing us back
into a new year national lockdown with
all
the damage that would mean the tough
measures in our winter plan
are the best way to avoid this outcome
all our friends around the world are
grappling
with the same question of how to keep
people safe
without retreating into a winter of
hibernation
in italy there's a nightly curfew
in germany hospitality will remain
closed until the 20th of december
and in france until the 20th of january
across the whole of the uk measures
remain in place to control the virus
under our winter plan england will
return to a tiered system
of local restrictions our decisions
on which enter which area enters which
tier
are based on public health advice
according to five indicators
cases across all ages especially the
over 60s
the rate by which cases are rising or
falling
the percentage of those tested in a
local population
who have covered and the pressure on the
nhs
we're publishing data packs setting out
the reasons behind the decisions
in each area to find out how this
affects you log on to gov dot uk
where all the information is available
i'm sorry to confirm that from wednesday
most of england
will be in the top two tiers with the
toughest measures
and i know that this will bring a great
deal of of heartache and frustration
especially for our vital hospitality
sector
our pubs our restaurants our hotels in
so many ways the soul
of our communities and which
continue to bear a disproportionate
share
of the burden i really wish it were
otherwise but if we're going to keep
schools open
as we must then our options in bearing
down on the disease
are necessarily limited what we will do
is continue taking every possible step
to protect
jobs and livelihoods across the uk
these tougher tiers strike a balance
they're sufficient to continue
driving the virus downwards but it's
important to recognize
they're less intrusive than the current
national
measures in all tiers
shops gyms the leisure sector
hairdressers other forms of personal
care
places of worship will reopen
you will no longer be instructed to stay
at home though you should continue to
work from home
if you can the rule of six will once
again
apply in public outdoor spaces and
organize
uh outdoor sport can can begin again
but there's no doubt that the
restrictions in all tiers
are tough and i'm sorry about that
while the data is beginning to improve
the virus is still
prevalent and the faster we drive it
down the faster
we can lift restrictions and that's
exactly
what these new tiers are designed to
achieve
while the previous tiers slowed the
spread of the virus
they were never quite enough to cut the
odd the the reproduction rate of the
disease the r
down below one and keep it there so
areas did not escape whatever level
they were placed in our new approach is
to reduce
design to reduce r below one opening a
path for areas to move
down the scale as soon as the situation
improves and crucially
we now have the means to accelerate that
moment
of escape with rapid community testing
allowing anyone carrying the disease
including
those without symptoms to isolate and
thereby reducing the r
and the truth is that at least one in
three people
with covid have no symptoms at all and
maybe spreading it
spreading the disease without even
knowing that they've got it
the only way to identify them and
protect
everyone is through mass testing and
liverpool shows
what can be achieved in in liverpool in
the space of two and a half weeks
over 240 000 tests have been conducted
and together with the effect of the
national restrictions
this has helped to reduce the number of
cases in liverpool
city region by more than two-thirds so
having previously been in tier three
liverpool city region and warrington
will now be in tier two this is a
success story which we want other parts
of the
country to replicate so we'll work with
local government with
public health leaders and our fantastic
fantastic armed forces
to offer community testing to tier three
areas
as quickly as possible opening the way
for them to follow liverpool's example
now testing on this scale is untried
but in due course if it works
where people test negative it may also
be
possible for families and communities to
be
released from certain restrictions even
if
their home area stays in in tier three
the allocation of tears will be reviewed
every
14 days starting on the 16th of december
so your tier is not your destiny
every area has the means of escape
and i have no doubt that together we can
get through this winter
suppress the virus until vaccines come
to our aid
and then we can reclaim our lives and
all the things that we love